Microsoft has announced they are
discontinuing the clipart that comes
with Windows they're discontinuing it
the clipart graphics were terrible they
were corny nobody used them anymore they
were they were awful well there that's
where I have to disagree okay I am a fan
of fine art I know quality when I see it
I happen to be a bit of a collector so I
spoke to Microsoft this morning the
minute I heard the news yeah I picked up
the phone that's shaped like my hand
right and I said your imaginary flame
might annoy phone no but I did I called
him and I said I want that art you'll
got rid of it I want it so I bought up
the entire collection of Microsoft's
Windows clipart and I'm going to show
you my favorite ones these are all real
this is real clip art images I didn't
create these these are real I own them
I'm giving them names this first one is
a classic I'm proud to call em quarters
that techno that loves to eat water yeah
I call this one who's gonna burn out and
die in three months this guy
I like that one I call this one five
increasingly acceptable ways to tell
co-workers you're gay way to do it
you're doing that a lot they already
know I call this one me and my
co-workers just shared a giant graham
cracker with a death row inmate these
are mine now killing I call this one
avoid alcohol during pregnancy or you'll
give birth to a human candle I call this
one who forgot to pay the gravity bill I
call this one who cares if I just got
laid off as a security guard my Turtles
number one and finally I call this one
Brad had chosen correctly the green
penis was the fastest
Wow
you